good morning good morning for all of you
in a morning time zone
welcome to a
stock live
i'm so glad that you are able to join us
here
and
take time out of your busy schedules to
learn more about nutritional solutions
for your questions with ask doc live
my name is rebecca kozak i will be your
host for the next two hours and i am
joined with my amazing co-hosts jonty
mccollier ruth ellen sanchez and nasima
omar
and we are here to help you get
information in regards to what you can
do
as in an empowered individual
to address health concerns and help you
find a journey to optimal health
so
this program
is of course being sponsored by
askdoclive.com
but we want to make sure that if you
were
sent to this program to watch this
program and get information or
ask your questions that you get back
with the person that shared this program
with you
okay
if nobody shared this program with you
then please go ahead and visit our
website at stocklive.com
and you will find a store that has all
of the products that dr wallach will be
speaking of today including his most
popular publications the good foods bad
foods list and if you have
questions specifically regarding
yourself or a loved one we do have a
contact us there
where you can send us an email and one
of our certified holistic health coaches
will get back with you with
the answer or information to help you
find the answer in regards to
your health questions
so i just have to remind you
that
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician
this content
the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation in a world where the
food supply
is
deplete and void of the needed nutrition
the body needs
not just to survive but to thrive
so fda
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
cure diagnose any diseases
we bring you good news the genetic
theory
has been proven incorrect through the
science of epigenetics
epigenetics is the study of how your
behaviors and environment can cause
changes that affect the way your genes
work and with epigenetics you are an
empowered individual and have more
control than you think of your health
journey we invite
you to feel the difference with the
options that are shared in this program
and to guide us
we are
absolutely honored to have one of the
founding fathers of epigenetics here to
share the best options to obtain and
maintain
optimal health dr joel wallach welcome
dr wallach we're so excited to have you
here
well thank you rebecca and john t and
ruth ellen and the sema the whole team
thank you for all the good things you
guys and gals do we just appreciate it
and thank you for all the kind words
um we have so much to deal with it's
very scary because this covet thing is
spiking again
and um it's because of our pre-existing
conditions obesity diabetes our heart
disease hybrid pressure
things like asthma
irritable bowel syndrome
gluten problems all these things are
contributing
to a lowered immune system which makes
us susceptible to
the covet thing i'm just going to give
you a few figures these are this
morning's figures
i haven't gotten any new ones since
early this morning
right now we're at 43 million
of 532
306 infections now here's the scary one
uh dead we're
703 thousand 703 thousand dead
now you go back to 1918 1919 the spanish
flu they had 675 000 dead it was
supposed to be the worst
killer pandemic ever in the history of
america and right now we have 28 000
more dead than they had during the
spanish flu and it doesn't seem like
we're near the end of this thing
and so i can see where we could get up
to
um a million dead right now or three
quarters of a million dead
and so it's very scary
because
which i say there's so much incorrect
information going out there people are
doing a lot of the wrong stuff
now we do have a new cd coming out
it should be
available today so you can go ahead and
order
drjwalik.com
drjwawk.com www.drjwalk.com
it's dr wally's law a photosynthetic
dysfunction
this should be disruption and global
warming dr wallach's
photosynthetics
disruption in global warming
and it goes into all the extinctions and
why we're in trouble being
going through an extinction ourselves
you go back you know 500 million years
ago
there was 12 major mass extinctions the
big five ones are called the big five
and thousands of species now listen to
me thousands of species disappeared
over a hundred thousand year period of
500 million years ago called the big
five mass extinctions
and uh all the experts saying we don't
know why
it could be this could be that we don't
know why and then the dinosaurs then
disappeared
after at 400 million years ago took a
hundred thousand years for
um
20 billion dinosaurs a thousand species
of dinosaurs if you if you put in the
water the ones in the water and the
flying dinosaurs was like 160 000
species all disappeared in a hundred
thousand year period
we have the dead zones in which there's
no life the biggest one is in india
um
in the arabian sea
uh where it's got sixty three thousand
seven hundred square miles of dead zone
uh we got the second biggest dead zone
here at the gulf of mexico it's six
thousand three hundred square miles of
dead zones and there's more dead zones
starting
the newest one
number 401
dead zone is on the pacific coast of
oregon because the columbia river basin
has 250 dams
shutting off the food supply to the
algae no oxygen so that's why there's a
dead zone at the delta there of the
columbia river
and then
the reefs are dying because of man-made
dams queensland where the great barrier
reef is 1400 miles long
um 2 900 small reefs and 900
small islands
and
the center of the great barrier reef is
dying because they have 183
dams damming up the food supply to the
algae which provides the oxygen for the
coral polyps which make the reefs the
northern 25 and the southern 25 percent
are okay because the
rivers are still
unblocked so the food is getting to them
and so forth and we're we're in trouble
now as far as getting to we're in big
trouble
okay our goal is to help you add 25 to
50 healthy years your life
and uh you know we i want everybody to
be super centenarians 110 years old or
older now here's the scary thing this is
this is one of those stories that makes
you cry this just happened just a couple
of days ago i don't know if you got the
story where you live
there's these twins
these these twins
15 months old two beautiful girls
15 months old
um the father is supposed to drop him
off at the
um
daycare before he goes to work he puts
him in the back seat of his suv he
drives to work he works all day uh after
work he goes to the daycare he says i'm
here to pick up my girl he said we
didn't leave him off this morning so he
runs home and they weren't there and
he's running around trying to find him
in the meantime they're dead in the back
seat because they were nine hours in the
back of his suv and it's like 100
degrees in carrollton georgia
and it's 120 degrees in the in the truck
and that he roasted his two daughters
like the roast chickens in an oven
nine hours in the oven
okay
now
it just makes you want to cry but these
are the sort of things just like that
couple and their child and the dog that
died up in yosemite national park they
couldn't find any drugs in them they
didn't find any bullet holes why'd they
die well they died of hypoxia
all these sort of things this guy
couldn't remember that he put his
daughters in his back seat and he's
supposed to drop him off he just went to
work because of hypoxia it didn't have
enough oxygen for his brain to work
properly
and
people go to their doctors
for depression headaches
migraines all this kind of stuff we've
talked about these victory gardens and
i'm glad to hear that um rebecca is
putting
the plants in her house and her office
and so forth uh every window in your
house should have a couple of potted
plants around it and you should be using
our plant arrival minerals two ounces
per pint of water
don't just water your plants because the
plants cannot do photosynthesis without
20 nutrients nine macronutrients
and 11 micronutrients are required for
the process of photosynthesis they never
talk about that they always talk about
sunlight
and chlorophyll that's all they talk
about they never tell you about the 20
nutrients that the that the chloroplasts
need to perform photosynthesis and
that's one of the reasons why we're in
trouble
well
um
this this comes down to
a massive problem
in the industrialized world
and of course if you
create what i call victory gardens in
your house in your your decorative
plants around your house your gardens
where you grow tomatoes and bell peppers
and onions and radishes and corn and
stuff like that
they'll create more oxygen and all these
sort of weird things go away
well all of the um
these thousands of species that died
over 500 million years including the
dinosaurs and triple trilobites and
stuff like that and then the dead zones
and the reefs dying and our problems
these are all caused by
a lack of nutrition
to the
algae that produces the oxygen for the
coral polyps
okay and for the algae that produces the
oxygen for the trilobites and all the
other critters in the ocean plants and
animals that require oxygen that's why
there's these dead zones and this is
where we're having things happening now
that happened 500 million years ago
now all of these terrible mass die-offs
occurred during periods of glaciations
there was obviously no human beings 500
million years ago there is no
man-made dams back then but the glaciers
produce marines m-o-r-a-i-n-e-s
that are dams and they they stop the
food supply
to the algae which produces
the oxygen so this is very very scary
stuff
but we can control it if everybody knows
about it so that's why we came out with
this new cd dr wallach's
laws of photosynthetic disruption and
global warming um we're going to come
out with a small book about the size of
a cell in your head 25 different
diseases of osteoporosis would be a book
about that size of the same title that
should be out in a couple of months but
this but the cds available now
it's actually a soundtrack from a zoom
that i did with pharmacist keith
and it's very very descriptive
and so we need to get on this big time
so we can add 25 to 50 healthier
people's lives
over to you rebecca
all right thank you so much dr wallach
that's a lot of great information stuff
that you haven't shared before and and i
know our listeners greatly appreciate
having more of the things that
interest them
spoken about because not many people are
dr wallach
and you're not afraid to and that's one
thing that i just absolutely love about
you
is you're not afraid to to bring up the
real concerns
well the truth is powerful
and um
i'm certainly not in the class with
these guys but this is what made moses
great and the ten commandments this is
what made jesus great it was all of the
truth that he spoke
and of course the romans didn't like
that that's why they crucified him okay
but he got his truth out and so
um in this
book
the subtitle is going to be the same as
the title of this um
cd we're putting out
but the the big title on the book is
going to be
let's see here the third testament
wow
the third testament
okay because it goes in the same vein as
moses and the ten commandments and jesus
and all the things that he shared with
us okay and and all of us all you and me
and everybody else we're kind of like
they're
um
[Music]
they're
which i say
we are their angels we are the ones who
are doing all the footwork because you
know
even god
has angels helping him okay do things
and so
you have to have an army to pull off
this information
spreading and so
um
this book i'm going to call it the third
testament
and you know there's going to be some
people that hate me for saying that
there's going to be some people that say
why did he do that there's some people
going to say that that was kind of a
good idea
okay because it's in the same vein it's
giving you
life
life-giving
information that you can share with the
people you love your community your
family
and the world
and because it's at that level it's at
that level of life-giving
and life-saving because of these mass
die-offs and mass extinctions
this really
requires an army to spread the
information
and we will be able to save humanity
otherwise we're we're in trouble we're
in trouble and see the doctors have
missed it by a billion miles
they thought that the vaccination was
going to save everybody
uh
well the vaccine they missed it by a
billion miles because the vaccination
will do certain things
okay but
um
it doesn't have nutrition in it
so you still have to deal with that part
and it doesn't vaccinations don't tell
you to do the right things and not do
the wrong things you still have to deal
with that
and so
we're reminding everybody about the ten
commandments reminding everybody about
all the wondrous
um
quotes that jesus left for us
and so we have to
um make sure that everybody of course
i'm getting a lot of stuff
from the muslims and muhammad and from
india and their peoples and so in this
new book there's going to be stuff from
all the great cultures on earth that
believe in god
and are going to take their greatest
quotes and things and put them in there
and that's why i'm going to call it the
third testament
well and something that i really
appreciate dr wallach is
you know you give credit where credit is
due and that's going back to the creator
oh absolutely
one one there's no doubt about it
we are not here by accident and
absolutely you are not here by accident
um
and we we all have a purpose and those
of you who are watching this program
with us
you are not here by accident the
information that you're going to be
hearing today needs to be spread around
the world over and over again
because it is giving you information
that is going back to
the root causes
of
breakdown and and dis-ease within the
body
and i love dr wallach that
you know god really put
early
in your life
a situation when i was nine years old
yeah yeah and and
gave you the
wisdom way back then
as to what needed to be done
to help yourself
and 20 20 doctors had failed the family
20 doctors couldn't figure it out they
were just going to institutionalize me
and in three days
time
i
got rid of my problem just by
supplementing with nutritional
supplements we had been giving the
animals
so you went from
wanting them wanting to institutionalize
you
to you then going through the
institutions
and coming out on top
and that's that's a true success story
that i absolutely love dr wallach
um and and you don't take all the credit
for yourself i mean you have put so much
into it
but you have given
god the credit
for giving you what you i i have an
emergency person at the front door here
can you just carry on for about two
minutes i'll be right back absolutely
absolutely
all right well everybody i just want to
again thank you so much for joining us
here on ask doc live for those of you
who are here with us on the program live
we do have the chat
options open
where you can
make sure you turn that chat on because
ruth ellen and nasima and jaunty are
sharing information in that chat to help
you find information about what you
might need
to
be empowered
in that chat but with that chat being on
there is no solicitation folks please do
not promote anything of your own going
into that chat this is a resource
to be used for the greater community
and we want to make sure that if
somebody sent you to this program that
you get back with them
in regards to getting the information
that you need getting the products that
you need in order to meet your health
goals all right
um
we are very honored to be able to
provide this resource to you
and
bring dr wallach
um
here for you to be able to ask questions
so if you have questions
in the zoom
menu
there is an option to raise your hand we
will be going through
the hands in the order that they are
received so make sure that if you have a
question you get your hand raised
in the zoom option you can
click on reactions and you'll probably
find the raised hand there
um for you to be able to raise your hand
and ask a question
all right everything okay dr wallach
everything's okay but i was expecting
some papers today but guess what they
appeared now
but this guy's banging on the door and
ringing the bell and i was afraid he was
gonna turn around and leave without
laying the papers on the front porch so
i said i better get him
nope
absolutely absolutely
well dr welch let's go to our first hand
that is raised this morning okay
and jane go ahead and unmute yourself
good morning
dr wallach i've been on the protocol for
osteoporosis of the skull for a year
and i've made great recovery i have a
slight bit of tinnitus
very slight that's still there but my
primary problem right now
and it's
i heard you talk about a
touch on it last time
uh is weak in muscles i'm having trouble
when i'm even standing just keeping my
back erect i want to end up falling over
it's easier for me to walk and that's
outrageous okay
well first of all um let's see here do
you have any numbness or tingling in
your hands
no i'm taking a lot of the collagen i'm
taking a lot of good
it's
slightly cold
and they slightly in here but
okay
have you had have you had uh some
improvement your hair color have away
completely absolutely okay so yeah you
can see yeah we're getting a lot of dark
color coming in very good yeah
absolutely so because because white
grain silver hair has nothing to do with
age it's all it's due to a nutritional
deficiency
and that same deficiency will cause
varicose veins spider veins do you have
some of those
no
okay good right and then of course you
get a terrible sudden deaths from
aneurysms in your brain and ruptured
aortic aneurysms can be caused by the
same deficiency that causes gray hair so
i'm glad to see your hair color coming
back now to deal um
with the
little bit of residual
trouble sleeping too
okay all right
and so what do you weigh
jane i um 112 i've lost weight using the
keto bars okay how tall are you
um 410 again i'm a person that's lost
four inches
okay yeah and so you had a tremendous
um
uh shrinkage of connective tissue the
discs are shrinking and the vertebrae
are getting closer together and that's
why you're shrinking that's putting
pressure
on the spinal nerves to go to your arms
and spinal nerves that go to your back
and spinal nerves go to your legs and
all that kind of stuff
and so this is all going to
and you may even regain an inch or two
in height
okay because of all this as a
supplementation
um
and uh let's see here so you want to
keep going don't don't relax you want to
keep taking at 112 pounds i would take
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month get an extra bottle of saline so
you can take three of those twice a day
there's one bottle of our selenium with
the five cofactors in it um very
important five cofactors so once you get
another bottle of our slime so you can
take three twice a day once you get two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three breakfast three atlantic
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote manage a pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
in your
vertebrae uh in your disc between the
vertebrae also in your muscles now the
muscles are connected with tendons and
ligaments all of which are connective
tissue the muscles
have all these different muscle fibers
but in between the muscle fibers there's
also like a little thread like strip of
connective tissue there's connective
tissue in the walls of your arteries
there's connective tissue
in your veins
as well as your veins
and so um
what you want to do is make sure you're
taking that that glucogel three with
each meal it'll be two vials a month
and
um
you're going to notice that he and that
extra selenium which is very very
specific for muscle tissue both heart
muscle and also skeletal muscle your
arms and legs and back and so forth
but your recovery is going to speed up
if you add those extra things okay and
then give us a call in two weeks give us
a call next time you go to the doctor
yeah you know because people are going
to hear your story
you have such a beautiful story
we can't thank you enough for calling us
thank you so so much jane
thank you
all right and yes i remember jane almost
a year ago
and how white her hair was and the color
and the color of her skin and
i think it's just fantastic
in an amazing change positive change
back in her hair and skin
yeah
that's beautiful jane thank you so much
for being on this journey with us
all right next dr wallach let's go to
lorraine who has her hand up
lorraine you're right and unmute
yourself
hi good morning good morning lorraine
how can we help you
okay so last month i called in and but
there's something new now
so last month i
reported that i was diagnosed with
asthma but you know they say it's coming
from acid reflux
but i was having a lot of like
lightheadedness dizziness and almost
kind of real sensitivity a little to
light so they did an eeg and my doctor
told me yesterday that
they saw seizure activity
so
he put me on a medication i took it once
and
it i just couldn't function it made me
so drowsy and sleepy
but
okay well let me back up let me bank up
and ask you some questions here how old
are you
uh 63 i'm 5'1
what do you weigh
uh 112.
okay do you have any other issues do you
have any high blood pressure diabetes
no
my
ring no
i'm sorry i missed that you're bringing
ringing ringing ears okay okay
okay so you have tonight just ringing
ears okay yeah
yeah varicose veins too varicose veins
okay
this is all um osteoporosis of the skull
all right
and you're you're how old
66 63 63 yeah okay so um
you know the doctors missed it by a
billion miles all right
and so um do you have any um other
trouble do you have any irregular
heartbeat or a rapid heart rate or
afib tachycardia once in a while my
heartbeat is irregular they've checked
my heart and they said i don't have a
fib
but um
what did he call it
tachycardia bradycardia
what was it
yeah i think it's atrial tachycardia or
something
but it's not afib
okay yeah it could be tachycardia or
bradycardia
yeah it's not all the time you know i
think when i progress it'll just yeah it
comes and goes all right so
um
do you have anything going on in your
back or your legs
uh
sometimes my legs feel
kind of tingly i i think i've had injury
to my spine so i don't know if it's
coming from that
okay so
down my arm
okay tingling down your arms yeah your
skull is squeezing squeezing your spinal
cord the spinal cord is coming out of
the back your skull is squeezing your
spinal cord and that's where you're
getting tingling down in your arms
okay
all right so here we go
um and a lot of this you're already
doing but this is for other listeners as
well so you need to get rid of all the
bad foods to maximize absorption no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat product notes no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
ones need to go and you can get the good
food bad food list from rebecca she'll
see if you get the good food bad food
list
and then at um
let's see here
at uh 112 pounds is that right
yes
yeah 112 pounds i want you to take one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
get another bottle of our selenium so i
want you to take three of our selenium
twice a day
um take
half a dose for everything else
twice a day and then i want you to get
um our msm get two bottles of remnants
to take through the three of the lunch
through dinner time and this is going to
help support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone breaks your bone cell in
the skull in your muscles in your back
and so forth and so um and also the same
nerve
that does it causes irregular heartbeat
and afib and everything when it gets
squeezed uh people get copd
uh
dry non-productive cough asthma is
caused by a different deficiency it's
actually a nutritional deficiency that's
always is secondary to
gluten intolerance do you have anything
going on in your skin any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis
no they tell me that asthma is secondary
to the reflux
well uh i don't think they know what
they're talking about
okay
and then
also
um
do you have anything going on with your
bowels any constipation diarrhea
irritable syndrome diverticulitis celiac
disease
no i mean once an oil constipation but
hardly
okay so don't forget you need to get rid
of the gluten no wheat in the body ryan
oates i mean you cannot have one cheat
day a week no no no
because
if you take if you have gluten one day a
month it's going to keep you in trouble
you can't have it can't even say the
word everybody in your household dog cat
bird fish spouse roommate kids
grandmother everybody's got to be drop
dead gluten free so there's no cross
contamination and the food preparation
surfaces right
and the couches and beds and so forth
give us a call every couple of weeks
because you're going to have a great
great story the fact that you're kind of
improving in certain areas
um
the asthma should go away very quickly
just take everything don't say well
there's so many of these i'll just take
one a day instead of what the bottle is
saying you know you take the doses the
bible says okay
now what did you say half a half a dose
of everything else
yeah half a dose of everything in the
it's because you're only going to get
because you only weigh 112 pounds you're
gonna get one
heart pack so if you take a half of
those of all that stuff twice a day half
a dose of breakfast haven't done it they
say take two tablets a day take one
breakfast one dinner time all right oh
okay okay and then but also
um
the
the selenium uh i need you to take
because i needed to get those five
cofactors and selenium you need to get
another bottle of slime so you can take
three twice a day you're gonna take a
full dose of the selenium twice a day
now what about the epilepsy thing
epilepsy do you have epilepsy
well that's what they told me yesterday
they did it
and they yeah do you have do you have
seizures
no but i keep getting um lightheaded and
dizzy and bright okay now okay stop
if you get lightheaded do you ever get
dizzy or sleepy a half hour after you
eat an hour after you eat
you know you have a big you have a big
dinner then you go sit sit in the couch
and fall asleep watching tv
no no if i eat something that has sugar
i'll fall asleep but i rarely eat sugar
okay okay we'll shop yeah you have
what's called reactive hypoglycemia
which is a pre-diabetes so i also want
you to get two bowels a month or
sweeties get two bowels a month of
sweeties take three of those twice a day
and that'll stop all that you have a
pre-diabetes
aka reactive hypoglycemia
and that's why you're having all those
symptoms and again the doctors have
missed it by a billion miles
what about what it when it shows on the
eeg though
well when you have low blood sugar it
affects your heart it affects everything
your brain how your brain works
it affects everything
it's kind of like when you don't have
any gasoline in your car
okay
all right
all right thank you lorraine
thanks
now dr wallach um
arthur wrote in and he has suffered an
tia
which is a transient isometric attack
stroke
ischemic ischemic ischemic systemic
thank you very much
the blood supply was cut off
um and now he has uh left side and leg
and arm impairment
he wants to know what he can do to heal
his brain and restore optimum
mobility
okay how old is he what does he weigh
how tall is he he's 67 years old
158 pounds at five foot five
okay
yeah five foot five a guy could weigh a
hundred and um
fifty 160 pounds so 158 pounds is about
right
and um but when he has leg and arm stuff
uh he has obviously approaches to the
skull squeezing the spinal cord is
coming out of the back of the skull
that's the arm stuff and then the leg
stuff
um he's got sciatica low back stuff and
so the
um discs between the vertebrae and the
back are shrinking the vertebrae and low
back are getting closer together
smashing the sciatic nerves coming out
from the
lumbar spinal cord and causing all this
stuff going down in his legs that's
called sciatica or periph he's got
multiple peripheral neuropathies you
know another doctor would say you got
peripheral neuropathies oh my god okay
well
it's all because
of malnutrition
to the
connective tissue
and transient ischemic attacks which
means he gets light hitter or he might
go to sleep
uh he might have reactive hypoglycemia
because the arteries are getting cut off
uh
because of pressure and he's going to
sleep ischemic attack meaning he might
have a heart pain because the arteries
in the heart are shutting down
the coronary arteries and causing heart
pain because the heart arteries are
constricting and not letting enough
blood through to the heart so it could
be in the brain the heart kidneys could
be all over the place
and so at 158 pounds i want him to get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread right notice no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go and then 158 pounds i wanted
to have two healthy brain hard packs per
month two healthy brain hard packs a
month to full dose everything twice a
day i wanted him to have two bottles a
month at the msm so you can have three
with each meal
they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between a
vertebrae bone makes your bone cell
and then
he needs to
also
have some collagen so i want him to take
two ounces a day of our cal tidy because
that'll save him from having to take
three products he'd take one the cal
tidy has the liquid calcium it's got the
vitamin d3 you've got the liquid
glucogen in there and he can take it out
and some breakfast outside dinner time
it'll be two quarts a month
and now let's see here oh also i'd have
them take
um three bottles a month of our ultimate
daily classic tablet so i can take three
with breakfast three of the lunch for
dinner time and they will support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart the
kidneys his legs every place but also
support healthy blood pressure
and so let's go that direction and uh
you know give us a report every couple
of weeks because these things turn
around very dramatically i deal with
professional athletes olympic athletes
university athletes
uh all the time
uh who have these issues and so
i really deal with thousands of these
people a year so i'm very experienced
with this sort of picture
awesome thank you so much dr wallach
and again for all of you that are
watching this replay or here with
us live you will be able to find the
replay of this program at askdoclive.com
so if you are on live with us and
listening just go ahead and listen and
then you will be able to go back to the
website and
stop write down stop write down whatever
you need and get with the person that
invited you to watch this program
dr wallach let's go to our next hand
that is up right now and
is it kumai
or kumi
please correct me i want to make sure i
say your name right it's so important
welcome you're online with dr wall hi
yes my name is kumi
welcome to me thank you very much
uh how can we help you
yes i had a session with susan
and she told me that
it's good that i see you
uh she said
uh i need to get estrogen
also she found that
i have something going on on the right
uh
right belly below the
um
ribs above the
maybe ovary
and i i feel there is uh
i'm a massage therapist so i massage
myself my belly and i feel this cyst or
gas or something bumpy
all the time
also
last year i had a corporate
march 2020
i had it as a
tonsillitis
and since then uh
after that
it it kind of shrinked i i feel all my
muscles ligaments shrink
and i felt like a turtle all my limbs
and neck
like going in
okay and all right let's stop let's stop
there for a minute okay do you have any
do you have any other things like um
diabetes or high blood pressure i have a
i have uh ulcerative colitis and
psoriasis
but i'm managing them well
okay arthritis colitis
and psoriasis okay no no arthritis oh
okay
maybe arthritis yes
okay aren't you so you have joint
problems
yes all the joints feel very tight
okay okay so you might have arthritis
colitis does this
by diarrhea constipation irritable bowel
syndrome celiac disease what
um
i
in the beginning i started to have in
2010 that time it was bleeding but now
i'm managing and by taking supplements
and
i have no vowel problem okay i need you
to listen because
your symptoms
all say you have bowel problems all
right psoriasis is due to very specific
nutritional deficiencies which show up
in the skin
dry
skin with you know flaking and itching
and all that kind of stuff
now this is due to a very specific
nutritional deficiency which always is
secondary to to gluten problems
uh colitis is secondary to gluten
problems whether it's called colitis or
irritable bowel syndrome or celiac
disease or crohn's disease or
diverticulitis is all the same
and arthritis
every joint the body whether it's your
tmj you know your your jaw joints or
your shoulders your neck your elbows
your wrists your knees your hips your
ankles your feet um these are all
nutritional deficiencies
and the tonsillitis could be also from
the osteoporosis of the skull squeezing
the ninth cranial nerve the
glossopharyngeal nerve causing pain in
your throat and tonsils and so on
and now the ovaries stuff there's
another picture
so here we go and um
how much do you weigh what's your body
weight
and how tall are you
five even
okay and what's your age
thank you kumi okay here we go
you need the good food bad food list
absolutely drop dead no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread around notes no sugar there
are no such things as gluten-free oats
gluten in oats is called gliadin is
still gluten
no sugar no carbonated drinks even the
diet ones have to go
and then
i want you
120 pounds because you have all these
issues
i need you to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
per month we can cut it to
maybe one healthy brain hard pack per
month so you get down to 110 pounds but
you have all these issues so i want you
to take two healthy brain heart pattern
a month to full dose full dose
everything twice a day full dose of
breakfast we'll go to dinner time
once you get two bottles a month for msm
so you can take three at breakfast
street lunch street dinner time and they
will support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes your bone itself
and um then i also want you to have the
cal toddy you can go ahead and take an
ounce of breakfast ounce of dinner it's
going to give you calcium vitamin d3 and
collagen
to support again
your joints and
so forth and skin i also want you to
have the hair skin and nails take two
bowels a month of the hair skin and
nails as the name implies
that uh help you with hair it'll help
you with your skin
and um but the skin again is due to
deficiencies
and between
the healthy brain and heart pack and the
msm getting off of gluten and taking the
healthy brain and heart pack and taking
the hair skin and nails three of those
twice a day two miles a month all these
issues are going to go away
all right you shouldn't have to manage
them
managing them is just like
um waxing your car when it runs out of
gas
if the car's out of gas let's wax it
okay and so you need all these nutrients
to maintain your body every day just
like you need oxygen every day you need
water every day you need this stuff
every day and kumi you cannot get this
by eating well what is your what is your
cultural background what country did you
come from japanese
you're japanese yes
okay
very good very good i spent a lot of
time in japan
um
and so i i know skoshy
you
yes
okay and so anyway so thank you we'd
love to hear from you every two weeks
because you're going to have a great
story you are going to have a great
story
okay thank you thank you for hearing
your testimony god bless you
thank you
awesome thank you so much kumi um for
sharing that information with us because
there's a lot of people dr wildlife to
have digestive
issues oh yes digestive issues it's it's
like
that's the
what would you call it that's like the
main corridor to the bottom body
yeah and access if you're having trouble
with digestion you ca even if you're
supplementing properly you can't get
much of it into your body and so
you're not going to see the benefit well
i tried it for six months didn't work
for me well did you give up gluten well
you know how could i give up oatmeal for
breakfast my grandmother had it for a
hundred years well yeah she was putting
wood ashes in her garden and wood ashes
in her food three meals a day are you
doing that well well no i have electric
stove well that's why you're in trouble
right yeah so it's yeah it's amazing
what the body can do when you give it
what it needs
absolutely can do some amazing things
now dr wilig i have a question it's
actually a series of questions about
things going on right now around the
world with this wonderful pandemic
and linda would like to know one does
the body make antibodies on its own
and if so how long does it take
the answer is yes
and usually it takes three days to three
weeks okay depending on what bug it is
and how intense the contact was and so
forth depends on how much nutrition
you're getting to support your immune
system which is your bone marrow
the bone marrow makes white blood cells
including t lymphocytes which is the
cavalry and the marines go and kill and
eat viruses and bacteria and that kind
of stuff and also your bone marrow makes
stem cells that actually make antibodies
and red blood cells and also platelets
and so you really really have to feed
all this nutrition to your bone marrow
you have to stay away from the bad stuff
so you can maximize absorption of that
nutrition
and then you'll very quickly make
antibodies now the question always comes
up well
if i've had
the
covid
and it's quieted down now but i still
have antibodies against it so they can
test me and i still show that i had
covered do i need to get a vaccination
well i would it's all it's everybody's
personal choice i mean i you know i'm
not demanding that everybody get it
people some people hate me because they
say you know you should get a
vaccination but
um
even though you've had covert
uh it still does not give you perfect
immunity
okay now the beautiful thing about
if you've had code you've got some
antibodies you're gonna take take a
vaccination get some more antibodies
if you do get coveted again you might
just have common cold like symptoms
and not get really sick
and this happens with a lot of diseases
where there's vaccines for you might get
the disease but it's very mild case and
it doesn't kill you
and so there is some value to taking a
vaccination even though you've you've
had a positive diagnosis for having code
all right and for those who have had it
and they still have some of the
aftermath of the
residual symptoms like unable to smell
unable to taste
what would you recommend dr wallick
nutritionally as the solution to this
issue
okay well still um
this has to do with osteoporosis of the
skull
uh and people who have osteoporosis cold
are very susceptible to getting bugs and
viruses and bacteria and things like
that including coping
because their immune system is down
they're not absorbing nutrition
and so i mean there's millions of people
out there who've lost their sense of
smell and taste and they've never had
the covet
okay so you can you can have those
nutritional deficiencies and get the
covet
and so doctors want to blame everything
on the coven
no
but you're you're more likely to get the
code
if your immune system is down
because you don't have nutrition if you
don't have nutrition you have all these
weird symptoms like tinnitus ringing in
the ears dizziness vertigo
there's a disease called paget's disease
i wanted to change it to wallex disease
because paget 100 years ago i was an
english
physician who autopsies and people
who would get dizziness and they would
die of something and he would do
autopsies on him and he realized instead
of the skull and these people being a
quarter of an inch thick like it's
supposed to be was an inch thick and he
named it after himself padgett's disease
he thought it was an autoimmune disease
the body's attacking itself so your
skull is an inch thick now instead of
quarter minutes thick
all right that's why it's squeezing all
these nerves as they're going through
the tunnels because those towels are
getting smaller your spinal cord is
getting squeezed coming out of the back
of the skull and you get all these
different symptoms and everything if
they go along with padgett's disease
well i wanted to change it to wallet's
disease because i showed that it's a
simple nutritional deficiency
and it's a totally different story if
you understand this nutritional
deficiency you can fix it by changing
your diet and supplementing as opposed
to well you've got an autoimmune disease
i can give you some symptom relief but
it'll just keep getting worse
and then you die from it because you're
just treating symptoms instead of
getting rid of it
okay
well let's get rid of it and not treat
the symptoms but treat the root cause
there you go
all right
let's go to our next hand dr wallach and
renee renee go ahead and mute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hello dr wallace hello
hi renee how can we help you
okay i just discovered you my husband
recommended me he forwarded me the email
and i am
i have a few issues going on lately okay
so
i had to go to emergency room pain on my
stomach it turns out it's a gastritis
within that my doctor also
diagnosed me with h pylori
so i just finished the antibiotics for
all of that
um
before all this i have
had um anemia
i've had constipation for years
i have i've had varicose veins for years
are you coloring your hair
yes
okay because the same deficiency that
causes varicose veins and hemorrhoids
also causes white hair and aneurysm so
you're getting a red warning light and
just coloring your hair is that going to
stop an aneurysm from farming no
you have to take the nutrient necessary
seriously your hair color comes back and
your veins and hemorrhoids
problems go away and then you know
you're not likely to have a ruptured
aneurysm in the brain or ar
but if you don't deal with that they're
in trouble okay
so i'm glad to see that you're
seeking some information here uh how old
are you renee
i'm 45.
and what do you weigh
179 pounds
okay
how tall are you five three
five three i'd like to see you wait
maybe 120
so i need to lose about 60 pounds here
all right anything else any diabetes how
about pressure
no but i've also
i had a ultrasound done and i have
stones in my gallbladder and the doctors
recommending
removal of my gallbladder
well give me 90 days first before you
make that decision okay
[Laughter]
is the question you need to ask your
doctor
does he have a kid in college and his
tuition do right now
yeah
are you getting the picture yes okay
so
get rid of all the bad foods good food
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat fire
ios no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go
and then
okay and then um at a hundred and see
was 179 pounds i want you to take two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
two healthy brain and heart packs a
month the full dose doing your breakfast
and dinner once you get two bottles a
month of our msm so you can take three
with breakfast three with lunch through
dinner time
um and i want you to they'll support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes bone
itself do you have any tinnitus or
ringing in your ears or dizziness
uh yes i get um vertigo sometimes um
associated with the anemia
i would stand up and get light-headed
that has
because i have changed i've lost some
weight i changed my eating habits
currently trying to do gluten-free i
have a son who has autism so we're
just
organic
gluten
you can eat organic foods that have
gluten in it you
can't have any gluten
yeah we're trying to eliminate little by
little we're we're getting there but
it's a process yes okay well the faster
you get it done the faster he'll recover
okay
okay so
um then like i say is the two hours a
month at msm
uh then i want you to take also an ounce
twice a day of the cal toddy so you get
the calcium the vitamin d3 and the
collagen the glucogen
which you take or a few quiet z take
three of those twice a day it's got
those six or eight different algaes and
things like that and seaweed from the
ocean with all these weird trace
minerals are good for immune system
and
um
[Music]
when you have pain in your stomach and
gastritis
um and you have obviously approached the
skull it's the same nerves do you ever
get hiccups
not not really okay do you ever get a
reaction to like uh afib
irregular heartbeat anything like that
um i have high stress speak i have four
children you know my son's no that's not
the answer to the question
uh do something
do you get any family regular heartbeat
sometimes i feel like
that's done they said i'm i'm fine
okay yeah there's nothing wrong with
your heart it says skull is squeezing
the 10th cranial nerve the 10th period
when it squeezes also gives you castro
creases and doctors want you to think
you have ulcers and they treat you
uh for ulcers
okay when really you just have
gastroparesis because you're you're
squeezing that 10th period or the
biggest nerve
now
um let's see here the stones in your
gallbladder we have what we call the
gallbladder in a bottle
it's called ultimate enzymes it's called
the gold bladder bottle because we have
all this
dried bile we go to the slaughterhouse
we get the bile from the gallbladders
all the cows and everything that they
kill for steaks
we put them in those ultimate enzymes i
want you to take two or three of those
say five to ten minutes for each meal
and
that bile will dissolve the gallstones
right so i say give me 90 days and if
you do this faithfully and before every
meal
and you stay away from fried foods
you don't want to lose your gallbladder
because it the good lord put it there
for a reason
yes
when you have a meal the gallbladder
squeezes and pushes bile down into your
stomach
and so
the bile helps you absorb essential
fatty acids and other
um healthy fats that you need for your
brain
and your eyes and your
your cell walls and all this kind of
stuff and if you take away your
gallbladder suddenly now
your your liver cannot respond properly
when you eat and so all the good stuff
you're eating goes out the other end
right right and so you don't want to be
taking your gallbladder out
thank you i i will
find another way i wanted
yeah well give us 90 days you'll be a
new woman give it call us every two
weeks because you're gonna have a great
story we love your smile you have such a
beautiful smile
uh
okay
so much
i appreciate it i bless you too thank
you
bye-bye
all right
thank you renee
we look forward to being on this journey
with you
and hearing all the great things that
are to come
now dr wallach dk has a question in the
chat here um and it's in regards to a
loved one who has been diagnosed with
colon cancer
a male
76 years old
250 pounds
um he had a stint put in in 1998
and he is taking blood pressure and
blood pressure medication statin and
blood thinner
okay
well he's got colon cancer right
that's that's what is mentioned yes
okay
well
all this other stuff is easy to deal
with do we know how tall this guy is
uh no it is not mentioned here
okay
all right um
the odds are 250 pounds is a little
heavy i would bet he's at least 50
pounds overweight and who knows if he's
my high five six he may be maybe a
hundred pounds overweight all right and
so
um he needs to get rid of all the bad
stuff
got to get the good food bad food list
immediately
um no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat bread around
those no sugar no carbonated drinks
these are all the things that causes
colon cancer it's not genetic it's not
autoimmune well i have five generations
in my family colon cancer that's because
they all ate the same way
okay
it has nothing to do with genes are
autoimmune
it's this dietary thing that caused it
then uh he needs to take two healthy
brain and heart packs for months full
roast everything twice a day i wanted to
get an extra bottle of sleep there's one
bottle of slim each of those bottle in
each of those kits but i wanted to get
another bottle of slim because when we
have three of our selenium at breakfast
lunch and dinner you'll be able to do
that with the two healthy brain heart
packs another bottle of selenium they
support the immune system and are really
really
uh
great to support your cancer fighting
systems and your immune system and your
and your colon and so forth
then because he has a history of his
stint which means they put something in
because he had coronary artery disease i
want him to have uh three bottles a
month of our ultimate daily classic
capsule take three with each meal they
will support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the heart the brain
the kidneys
which will help with his blood pressure
also
and let's see here
i also want him to have
two ounces a day of the cal toddy ounce
of breakfast sounds at dinner time he
can take um an ounce of that twice a day
he'll get the calcium vitamin d3 and the
collagen for his joints but i also want
him to have
two things uh one i wanted him to have
our fucoid z take three of those twice a
day uh he may even if finances are not
an issue you could take three three
times a day of the few quite see there
are all these uh uh algaes from the
ocean that have all these weird trace
mills in it to support the immune system
you could
take anywhere from three twice a day to
three three times a day in a few
coincidence i also want him to have
uh the
let's see here i want him to have the
cell shield rtq the q is the quercetin
which supports the immune system when
you have cancer then i also want him to
get our btt 2.0 tablets one to get two
vowels a month of those so we take three
of those twice a day they are not
interchangeable with the btt 2.0 or btt
2.5
powders because they're vitamins
minerals the tablets support the immune
system and also anti-inflammatory and so
we need to hear from him on a regular
basis and we're not claiming that we can
cure his colon cancer
but
we can
quiet it down
um if they didn't get it all okay and
because we don't know when he was
diagnosed was it yesterday last week
30 years ago we don't know any of that
okay and so
uh all we can say is that this is going
to at the very least uh give him more
time
if he said on the other end well you've
got six months to live we might give him
three years uh you know it's one of
those things that's gonna be positive
but i can't tell you
how positive without more information
right so i did get just now um he
received the diagnosis yesterday which
we know that's not when it started and
no surgery
or chemo have been done yet
okay
all right so
thank you for that information and that
helps us because again we don't know a
whole lot because we just know the
diagnosis occurred yesterday
we don't know how bad it is is it in the
lymph nodes is it stage three four is it
you know just as big as a p is as big as
a cantaloupe you know we don't know
anything
right
all right thank you so much for that
information dr wallach and i just
mentioned that they will find out
and for those of you listening
and if you hear any of the
recommendations or any of the conditions
that represent
something that you or a loved one
is currently experiencing
we
encourage you
to go back to
the replay and listen to the
protocol that dr wallach
provided
at our website askdoclive.com
we have all of the replays all the way
back to our very first program july of
available for you to use as resources to
help you and your loved ones find
nutritional options to achieving optimal
health
dr wallick we are at the top of the hour
let's go ahead and take a five minute
break
and then come back and answer some more
questions okay
let's do it
all right and everybody's
thank you so much for staying here with
us and being part of
our live askdoc live
audience
my name is rebecca kozak i again am your
host for this two hours and it is my
honor to be able to provide this
resource to you
for those of you who found this program
on your own feel free to go to our
website
askdoclive.com
you will find a store there where you
can find all of the products that dr
wallach mentions you can also find all
of his publications or the most popular
publications on our website as well
but for those who were referred to this
program by somebody specific
please get back with that person that
share this program with you
they
they care about you and they want to
make sure that you get exactly what you
need in order
for you to obtain optimal health as well
so we will be right back
um stay tuned don't go away stand up
stretch fill your glass with some great
water with a splash of minerals and
we'll see you soon
all right thank you so much everybody
for sticking here with us and giving us
that little break
again you are on with a stock live
where we are
excited
and honored to be able to provide this
resource to you with nutritional
solutions to your questions about health
and it looks like we are ready to go dr
wallach
go ahead and unmute yourself
how's that
that's fantastic and
let's just go right into the next
question and i
looks like lorraine might have um no go
ahead dr wallach we could say before we
go to the next question i just want to
remind everybody about
www.drjwalik.com www.drjwy.com
and this new book that i'm working on
the the first
chapter is going to be
a written version of the cd that's
coming out right dr wallach's
law of photosynthetic disruption and
global warming
and then
i've got
um
15 books
each chapter is going to be one of those
books
okay including
immortality
are all the long-lived cultures on earth
in that book immortality it goes for all
the things that they consciously do
proactively to live longer all the
things they proactively do
are not due to live longer
that book is is worth its weight in gold
because you save a lot of money save a
lot of unnecessary misery you know that
book um immortality there's a cd that
goes along with it beyond immortality
which tells you how to live to be 120
160 all that kind of stuff and some
people say who would want to live that
long
really if you could spend another 80
years with the person you love
wouldn't it be worth
changing your diet a little bit and
adding a few supplements
to have another 80 years
yeah especially dr wallach if you can do
it without pain
yeah exactly comfort
and so this is going to be
um a quite a project but in fact if they
figure well why just retype everything
because i already have most of this
stuff written up in these other 12 books
and so we'll just make each of those
books a chapter
in this new book
and so that's how this whole thing is
going to work it's going to be crazy and
so people can pick and choose depending
on what their subject is and so forth
you know they might buy three of those
books instead of all 12
and and so on
but
just depending on what
their interest is
and um
i've been working on this for a long
time and i figured this is the best way
to get the information out there and of
course
in the old days
um
they would have sermons on the mount
they could go and they'd speak on the
mountain and they'd have
50 or 100 or a thousand people sitting
there in the heat in the desert
listening to the sermon all right and so
now we have zooms and we have cds we
have dvds we have books and stuff
and so on plus we have these wonderful
zooms we're doing with you and your team
and i cannot thank you enough for
helping me get this information out
because we can help so many people avoid
so much misery
and add many many healthy years to life
a minimum a minimum of 25 to 50.
and my goal is to help everybody gain at
least 80 years and if they follow all
the stuff
in these cds and the books they can add
25 to 50 healthful years to their life
and save a lot of money and save a lot
of unnecessary misery okay back to you
well let's continue on with the sermon
on zoom
and
i i'm just i i love the fact that we can
do this dr wallach and we can reach so
many more people
not just in our backyards but around the
world
and we encourage each of you to share
this video with somebody else at least
one person
share it with somebody else and share
with them that there is hope
outside of chemicals because our bodies
are not chemical deficient
they're new
well most in most cases rebecca those
chemicals just manage the disease reduce
symptoms and people very thankful oh
i've been in pain for 20 years the
doctor gave me this new drug is just out
my pain went away in 12 hours i haven't
been without pain now for three days
i've been pain for 20 years i just love
my doctor i'm going to leave everything
in my will to my doctor when i die
because he got rid of my pain but the
disease is still there and that disease
will ultimately kill that person
okay but he's so overjoyed by getting
pain relief he's going to leave him his
house and his land and his cars and
everything and leave the kids out
well and so dr wallach there's one thing
that that i know from experience
yes i took
that
magic little pill
two hours two two years later though i
was on six not one
six additional pills oh my gosh
compensate
for what the others had done in other
areas of the body
so
i i just
my my heart really goes out to those who
have that bag full
of peels every month that they have to
take that keeps getting heavier and
heavier
and now
yes i have
pills that i use that i take
but i'm using food as medicine doctor
wallach
i'm using things that are supporting the
system
and not masking
and the greatest physician of all the
good lord put all this stuff on earth
for us to use
absolutely and i love the fact dr
wallach that he gifted you
with the knowledge and wisdom to put it
all together in a form that we can use
within our bodies
well thank you for the kind words
and i
yeah i just can't thank you enough
doctor well i told you how much i love
you and how
much i appreciate all that you've done
well they'll raise this travel ban soon
and we'll be able to have dinner
we're gonna do it
yes yes yes
all right let's go to the next hand up
dr wallach and i think lorraine might
have another question for you
ray did you have another question for dr
wallach
i wanted to go back about the epilepsy
thing because i don't want to take that
medication
and
[Music]
i mean
is it okay just not to take it or
okay well here's the deal if you're
having uncontrollable seizures you can't
safely drive or
you're you can't cook because you're
going to fall on the stove and all this
kind of stuff you might have to take it
for a while well i'm not taking i mean
i'm not having like seizures but
you know because
because i have the sort of dizziness and
sometimes things like well it did we
already went through the taste yes so is
it stop
well you already went through
i believe that your dizziness is called
vertigo it's due to osteoporosis of the
skull
squeezing the auditory branch of the
eighth cranial nerve
and
and anesthetizing you is not going to
solve the problem it's going to continue
to get worse
you need to get rid of the bad foods and
take the program that's going to rebuild
your skull
and the rest of your bones your body um
it's really sad the doctors think you
only get osteoporosis of your hips
okay they never think about your skull
because they say there's never been a
report of osteoporosis in the skull
that's because of pages and that's why
it's got to be changed from pages
disease to wallet's disease because he
believed a hundred years ago that it was
due to
an autoimmune disease of the skull the
skull was an inch thick instead of a
quarter of an inch thick but all those
tunnels that the spinal cord goes
through and the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves as the skull gets thicker those
tunnels get narrower because you know as
the skull gets thicker there's more
skull to smash those tunnels down to a
smaller size put pressure on the nerves
and you get ringing in the ears tinnitus
you get dizzy problems vertigo
you lose your sense of smell you lose
your vision get on a optic nerve atrophy
because the skull is squeezing the optic
nerve the optic artery the optic vein
and i've won so many bets from doctors
because i can take people who are
legally blind six eight ten twelve years
and in 90 days you could read 20 20
without glasses because
i dealt with the osteoporosis of the
skull instead of giving him a new pair
of glasses
okay
okay so give me 90 degrees and that's my
concern is giving me 90 days and only
you know whether you have to take that
medicine or not because if you're
falling down and hurt yourself i haven't
read that i haven't had okay okay if
you're just getting sort of dizzy stuff
it's called vertigo
okay
um
sometimes i have like twitching in my
arm or whatever but yeah well your skull
is squeezing your spinal cord is coming
out of the back of the skull
your spinal cord is formed in your brain
comes out of the back of the skull
that's one of those tunnels that gets
smaller when you have osteoporosis
called squeezing the spinal cord some
people get numbness in their hands they
say oh you have carpal tunnel syndrome
they'll give them operations in their
wrists because really the skull is
squeezing the spinal cord
okay
all right thank you
okay thank you lorraine
next let's
go to christy
christy go ahead and unmute yourself
hello christy how can we help you
hi how are you today
okay you look just like me
oh you can see oh you want to see me
okay
there you go here i am
okay no i can only see my i can
rebecca i can see myself twice i see
myself in a little there there we go
i can see now i can see rebecca
okay now you should be able to see
christy christie go ahead not yet
i don't see christy yet
uh hold on
can you see me now there we see christie
there you go
hi okay i'm 41 uh 152 pounds five foot
six and i've been having um you know
numbness in my hands i'm a physical
therapist so i use my hands a lot so it
started when i was uh pregnant with all
three of my children
um and now i feel numbness it's more so
at night and i also get it in my toes
but then also
um i've been having right breast pain
that kind of radiates into the axillary
region
i've had mammograms they said
nothing's there i've had that okay stop
stop and when you say right you have
pain in your breast itself or you talked
about in the area of your chest or what
no it's in the breast itself okay okay
but nothing there when they did the when
they did the mammogram
no no so um
i still
you know can actually i don't know if
it's lactation um because i can still
produce something so they tested the
pituitary gland okay okay stop when was
the last time you breastfed
uh oh god it was over two and a half
years ago okay yeah i shouldn't have any
leftover problems there all right do you
have any diabetes or hybrid pressure
uh no no pressure
since i've had kids though my pressure
was always like 109. now it's like norm
it's like 120 so for me i feel like
that's high you know because it had
never been like that but
do you have any skin problems any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis
no
are you coloring your hair do you have
any white gray or silver hair no
do you have any varicose veins in your
legs i do yes
okay
like spider veins so i guess that's
varicose correct yeah yeah those are
just small varicose veins um yep and
then uh let's see here uh do you have
any bowel problems any constipation
diarrhea irritable bowel syndrome celiac
disease crohn's disease diverticulitis
any of that kind of stuff
no no the only i acquired was my first
pregnancy was a hemorrhoid well it's
it's it's almost like an anal fissure
that kind of pops out and like tears a
little bit um but that would be
depleted
well hemorrhoids are varicose veins in a
funny place
yeah that's what hemorrhoids are okay
but they they usually go along with
white gray or silver here you don't have
one white hair in your head
no not yet i've been checking believe me
i'm 41.
okay well here we go
none of the bad foods no fried food no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no butter i know it's no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go 152 pounds i want you to have
two of our healthy brain and heart packs
per month full dose everything twice a
day once you get two bottles a month of
our msm's you can take three with
breakfast three with the lunch through
dinner time and they're gonna support
and promote means of prayer of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae um bone
makes it bone itself including the skull
and also in the walls of the veins and
arteries and so forth
and um don't forget that your skull is
squeezing your spinal cord as it comes
out of the back of the skull because the
spinal cord is formed in the brain comes
out back to the skull the about you
process all those tunnels get smaller
okay
and um
um
doctors never
think about that stuff or maybe they do
they just don't want to tell you what
they think they just because they have
another agenda who knows
um
and then i want you to have 152 pounds
once you take two ounces a day of our
cal toddy uh gives you the calcium
vitamin d3 and collagen uh take an ounce
of breakfast nonsense every two quarts a
month
and then
if you have pain someplace like you know
under your arm or on the side of your
breast or something you can take our cm
cream you do have to mix it up every day
because the cream will settle to the
bottom water come to the top so you have
to mix it up so it's uniform
distributed properly and apply that
you know like a tablespoon and apply
that to the area that's painful and
it'll give you a couple hours of relief
but if you do all this other stuff
within 90 days it should be
significantly reduced or gone
go ahead i'm supposed to get an mri with
uh what is it gandalonium today for it
because they
they can't explain why like i do notice
this heightened during like
pre-menstrual cycle um
even having it you know like i started
doing the keto diet and everything i've
eliminated a lot of stuff and all the
things that they say can trigger the
pain and it seemed like it was like
worse for a while like keeping me up at
night you know you lay on it it feels
like larger than the other
um do i go ahead and do the mri because
i actually have a schedule today i had
put it off for like months because i i
didn't want to go that far but i also
don't want to be like in i don't want to
be um you know well if it's scheduled
for today i'd go ahead and get it but i
would also add to add to your program
the
um
zero fm go ahead and get two bottles a
month of our zero fm take three three
yeah zera found this
x e r a um
fem
uh and it actually gives your ovaries
the raw material it needs to make
estrogen and progesterone okay
yeah because i had birth control pills
for like over 15 years until i got
pregnant so i feel like my hormones
don't even know how to regulate
themselves at this point and so yeah and
so don't forget to eat three eggs twice
a day do not take statin drugs
to lower cholesterol take three eggs
twice a day they have to be soft yolks
soft boils soft yolks soft poached off
yolks soft soft scrambled butter hard
bald eggs won't count and fridays will
cause cancer
okay
all right so call us you know call us
next
friday because you'll have the results
of that
mri
yeah
today or tomorrow whatever it is and let
us know what the results were okay
thank you i appreciate it okay god bless
you too
all right thank you christy and best
wishes and that
we look forward to following your
journey as well
dr wellick
we have a question that has to do with
the ultimate zinc liquid
can it be used as a topical for skin
ulcers and boils or would colloidal
silver be better
well if they're open wounds i would go
with the
colloidal silver
okay
and i would take the zinc
tablets orally
all right and anything else so i mean
we're looking at skin ulcers and boils
the root problem that dr wollock is
well the root cause of that is
nutritional deficiencies usually okay so
they need the hair skin and nails three
of those twice a day per hundred pounds
of body weight there's two balls a month
400 pounds of body weight they need the
90 essential nutrients uh wouldn't hurt
to you know per 100 pounds of body
weight get a healthy brain heart pack
don't forget the msm
which deals with the skin and all other
forms of collagen and connective tissue
and so on
and
i would i would use the colloidal silver
i've been doing it for 25 years four
drops
excuse me
uh four drop
four droppers full
um two droppers full under my tongue
a half hour before each meal and two
droppers full under my tongue 30 minutes
for a bedtime so it's like four droppers
full
uh
twice a day okay and so i go through two
of these bottles a month i've been doing
it for 25 years of colloidal silver
but if the
wounds are not open
then there's something else going on
there
all right so you can still do the
collateral silver
just in case
um
because it's very economical very cheap
much better than going to a doctor's
office getting surgery and prescription
for antibiotics all that kind of stuff
and so
but don't forget the hair skin and nails
because the odds are that this is all
caused by nutritional deficiencies and
the skin is just reacting to nutritional
deficiencies
all right thank you so much for that and
then and this nasima has a question and
she has a lady that's going on a no
histamine diet or a low histamine diet
because she breaks out in a red skin
rash that itches shortly after eating
anything
that is not super fresh or contains
histamines
and it lasts for about a day or so
before
it disappears
um
so dr wellick when we're looking at the
diet and things that are causing us to
have
a red skin rash and itchiness
i mean is it things that we're we're
allergic to is there something
you know within the digestive system
that we need to work on well it was
possible that she's allergic to
something if she's allergic to something
she should be able to figure it out you
know for a month to avoid this food
still have a problem yeah yeah do an
elimination done figure it out and you
know don't go and get scratched 80 times
and try to and pay thousands of dollars
when you can do it for free okay
um and that's where the book let's play
doctor goes into those kinds of
elimination dots they tell those kind of
things
um but it could be a little different
problem it could be that um
there's not enough nutrition
for the liver to work properly and it's
releasing histamine when you eat
okay and so
it could be a liver problem so this
person needs to be sure they're taking
the healthy brain heart pack and if they
only weigh 110 pounds to get another
bottle of our sleep make the liver happy
and so on and so go through all those
kind of things and
this is again where
um
doctors have an agenda
all right and boy they love somebody who
comes in with these weird things because
well we gotta run tests we gotta put you
in the hospital for a week and run tests
and got to put you here and do tests and
within five years you're on 30 different
prescriptions you're going to this
therapy session here in that therapy
session there and you're just a source
of income for this doctor because you've
got three kids in college and tuitions
due
but it's okay because insurance is
paying for it well that's right we're
not hurting the patient because
insurance is paying for it
oh
yes i get i get that quite a bit oh but
my insurance is paying for this i'm like
okay
and go ahead and keep keep feeding them
um okay so the next question dr wallach
has to do with discoloration on the skin
and small spots
this individual was told by the doctor
that it happens due to moisture in the
folds of the skin like on the chest or
back
and a prescription was given as a
shampoo for fungal stuff
and to be used as a body wash
what can we do naturally internally and
externally that would help get rid of
this naturally
i know
some of those anti-fungal
you know topicals are not healthy for
the skin yeah okay well again get rid of
all the bad foods no fried food you've
heard this before no fried foods no
processed meats oils or glutens and
wheat powder i know so sugar no
carbonated drinks even that one's got to
go
and then the healthy brain heart pack
again the msm again the cal todd
and i would also take the hair skin and
nails
throw that in there okay
and
um
then
it wouldn't hurt
if there's still a problem it wouldn't
hurt to get a hair nails to get the book
um
rare earthen cures in chapter 10 i
believe it is it tells you how to
collect the hair how to package it where
to ship it don't forget to put the check
in there because they won't run the test
without the check
and within a couple of weeks you'll have
two charts so one of which tells you
um where your nutritional nutrients
stand particularly the minerals okay are
they all in the range are supposed to be
they'll be kind of different but are
they all in the range are some high some
low are they all low if they're all real
low you're not absorbing
very efficiently all right and then the
other chart
um the second chart tells you all the
toxic minerals you're taking you know
lead and mercury and uranium and all
this other stuff
that you don't want
i get one of those tests once a year and
if you're doing the young judy business
as a business or you own a small
business
your your
plan will pay for this
as part of your health
plan for your business will pay for for
the hair analysis is not that expensive
and it will tell you something that can
add the information can add 25 to 50
healthy years your life because you're
very specifically asking questions about
do i have toxic metals i get so many
people rebecca who say oh yeah i was in
the military 25 years ago and i know i
was exposed to all these toxic chemicals
that's my problem have you ever had a
hair analysis no so i can talk them into
getting a hair now so get a hair
analysis come back no toxic metals
whatsoever
and so now you have to
really get busy you can't just blame it
on your military experience 25 years ago
they're just making it up because they
didn't you know the doctors couldn't
figure it out and so well it was
probably the fact that i was you know in
the military 25 years ago and got
expected got
exposed to some chemicals
no
no no
yeah some sometimes it's easier to to
pin to
not necessarily pinpoint but generalize
to make you feel better
um
but i love the fact that dr wellick you
get to the root of it all and
and address it as it is
now the next question dr wallach and
this is something i remember
when i was having babies
all of my friends babies were getting
tubes in their ears
thankfully
i never had to
had to make that decision but what is
your
opinion on putting tubes in babies ears
and lots of congestion and allergies
okay
well again the mother has to do all the
right stuff during pregnancy not to
expose kids to things that can be
allergenic
okay
also
um you know like drinking alcohol and
that kind of stuff
um also
and gluten
if the kid has swelling in the ears they
put tubes in their ears well that's just
a temporary fix why do they have
swelling in the ears
do they have something going on with
their glossopharyngeal nerve which has
to do is the ninth cranial nerve it has
to do with your throat and swallowing
and hearing and all that kind of stuff
uh also the eighth cranial nerve the
auditory branch of the atrial nerve can
be squeezed if the kid the baby can be
born with obviously approaches to the
skull if the mother wasn't supplementing
properly or if she was supplementing and
eat gluten not absorbing and so the
embryo didn't get what it needed so the
baby's born with osteoporosis of the
skull
babies get honestly approached to the
skull all the time some of them are
paralyzed from the neck down because the
skull is squeezing her spinal cord
and sometimes i wonder
not that i was paralyzed
but because i had so many different
things going on early in life
um i
was pretty certain i had osteoporosis of
the skull as a child
yeah it's very common it's very common
yeah
and
of course pediatricians they look
pediatricians love that one
well
yeah because i get the parents to be
giving them this and this and this and
they keep coming back and you know it
makes for certain repeat customers with
some high dollar
bills going into it and yeah and also
broken families there's a lot of times
you know when the kid has so many
problems that's enough to break up a
family
um
it's your fault no it's in your family
i guess what you're saying
absolutely
well let's go to the next hand that is
up dr wallach and that is rainy
and i'm hoping that i am pronouncing
your name correctly you are on live with
doctor walk hi
good morning can you hear me
yes
hi
okay um so this question is from my mom
um she tried to call in but she's a
little older and she doesn't understand
all the technology so i'm gonna try and
ask the question for her
um her issue is her blood pressure it's
unmanageable um every time she monitors
her blood pressure at home and it's fine
they have on two medications
uh
better tall and more sartan
doctor
her blood pressure is
up you know the numbers are just high so
they keep changing and have you have you
ever heard have you ever heard the word
fear
yeah i call it well fear and white coat
syndrome because i told her there you go
every time she goes into the office the
blood pressure is up okay how much does
she weigh how much does she weigh
she weighs 135.
how old is she 80.
okay
and she's how tall five foot four inches
five foot four yeah five foot four
uh she's she's okay at 135 pounds
and so does she have any other issues
any diabetes any arthritis any back
problems any memory problems or anything
she has knee knee problem knee knee pain
joint stuff like that she's had that for
a while
okay
all right well here we go
absolutely none of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no brother ryan
notice no sugar no carbohydrate or
drinks all the diet one's got to go
and then 185 pounds
excuse me 135 135 pounds
um
i wanted to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month get another bottle
of our saline so you can take three of
those twice a day everything else take a
half a dose of breakfast and half of
those to dinner so if the label says
take two a day take one breakfast one
dinner okay
okay half a dose twice a day of
everything except for the selenium i
want you to have her take three twice a
day so she'll need to get another bottle
so you can take three twice a day i want
to get
um
because she got knee issues and highway
pressure i want her to get two bottles a
month for the msm so you can take three
with each meal and then i want her also
to get the ultimate daily classic
tablets get two of those per month in
bottles a month so you can take three
with each meal they'll support healthy
blood pressure and healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries
and then um
for the knee issues and back issue 80
years old the odds are she's got
osteoporosis to skull and osteoporosis
everywhere else and so she needs to take
our cal toddy
135 pounds she can take one quart a
month take a half ounce of breakfast
half ounce of dinner it has the calcium
vitamin d3 and collagen in it
and if she wants to she she can put some
of her cm cream and trauma oil on top of
her needle give her two three hours of
of um pain relief by putting these
those things on her knee topically but
the high blood pressure is easy to deal
with
with again
with the ultimate daily classic tablet
so two of those bottles of muscle can
take three twice a day
if she's on medication for the highway
pressure don't cold turkey off the
medication but as the blood pressure
comes down slowly she can slowly reduce
the medication based on the numbers okay
okay
and usually within a couple of weeks
she'll be offering medication for blood
pressure if she's on medication um and
um this oftentimes is due to kidney
issues does she have any kidney issues
is she on dialysis anything like that no
okay good
all right so give us a call and of
course um
the
i'm going to come up with a pill
that that helps people
who see doctors
it's called doxillan it's called
doxillan
yeah she needs that now i have a
question you you said all that i tried
to write down as much as possible how
can i get this information um
all everything that you gave me because
i i
guess what they they post it it'll be
posted this afternoon it'll be posted
tomorrow it's on forever so go look at
it 10 times a day if you want and write
it all down okay cool okay
all right that's uh that's about it for
now i'll be calling back and i watch you
well i listen to you all the time on
coast to coast when you come on okay
okay yeah i'm gonna be on of course uh
um sometime next month okay
thank you
okay god bless thank you so much bye-bye
and thank you rainey and yes that's you
can find all of the replays for stock
live at askdoclive.com
as our website um for those of you again
who were invited to this program by
somebody specific get back with them if
you'd like to get some of the products
that you hear mentioned here today
or
if you have not been referred by
somebody specific and found this program
on your own
feel free to go to
askdoclive.com and you will find our
store there with dr wallach's most
popular books and we have a contact us
if you do not know exactly what you need
to take and when you would like to
consult with one of our certified
holistic health coaches go ahead and use
that contact us to send us an email and
one of us will get back with you
we also have a call team that is
standing by at 855-949-7234
and that is for people who were not
referred by somebody specific and have
never ordered any youngevity products
from anywhere any at any time so that
line is available for you as well
now dr wallach i have a question in
regards to s
um
and i don't have
if it's a male oh it is a male 5 foot 5
250 pounds
has a heart murmur
on blood pressure meds
and cholesterol meds
but it doesn't take them
regularly what is your recommendations
to to help address the heart murmur
blood pressure
issues and cholesterol
okay well cholesterol is one of your
best friends is the raw material to make
testosterone uh mr raw material will
make your brain 75 of the brain weight
is cholesterol 95 percent of the weight
of testosterone is cholesterol you do
not want to be on statin drugs because
if you're not
making
um testosterone you're not gonna have
much fun in life okay um here you're
gonna look like a
uh you're gonna look like a steer
instead of a bull
okay
so you do need to eat three eggs twice a
day with soft yolks
i would get off the cholesterol thing
cholesterol does not clog your arteries
it's eating fried foods and gluten that
causes clogging or he's not cholesterol
and then um at 250 pounds this guy
should be taken
to healthy brain and heart passion was
again the good food bad food list
another bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread right no sugar no carbonated
drinks needs um the um two
uh healthy branded heart packs from a
month to full glossing twice a day two
bottles a month of the
um msm so you can take three with each
meal and they will support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone rings and bone itself
also you can take
two ounces a day of the cal toddy gives
you the calcium vitamin d3 and and the
collagen to to
manage bones and cartilage and ligaments
and tendons connective tissue and all of
the connective tissue in the muscles and
so on i have a pressure he needs um
250 wouldn't hurt him to get three
bottles a month of the ultimate daily
classic tablets take three with each
meal and they will support healthy blood
pressure and healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the brain and the
heart and the kidneys and and so forth
and let's see here
um
i think that is going to
cover everything but i would still for
some anti-inflammatory stuff i would
throw in the fucoid z take two bottles
of that a month so we can take three of
those twice a day i would also throw in
the
btt 2.0 tablets they do not replace or
interchange with the btt 2.0 powder the
powders vitamins and minerals the
tablets support your immune system and
also are anti-inflammatory so i'd have
to take three of those tablets twice a
day it'll be two vowels a month and then
call us or email us every couple of
weeks because
this uh
sort of picture this guy's presenting is
very common and he will have a great
great testimony
for
um our
listeners now at five foot five i'd like
to see him weigh 160 needs to lose about
90 pounds so one meal a day i'd like to
start out with our keto bar you know
he's gonna need three boxes a month
there's only 10 bars in a box so you can
take one
a day uh it doesn't matter what meal it
is you can change it around depending on
the schedule
and um he'll lose a half a pound two
pounds a day especially getting off all
the bad foods plus taking one keto meal
a day uh he'll lose a half a pound two
pounds a day
and um
the rest of the meals he should eat like
an asian rice and sweet potatoes beans
squash
he can have corn
but no wheat butter in oats
he can have fish
there's no red meat and fish
i i have steak two nights a week i have
lamb chops from australia every saturday
uh night
i have gluten-free pizza the rest of my
meals during the week i put hamburger
patties on there or some fish
um
or maybe even um
sardines that are packed in water not
oil
all right and so then for breakfast i
had this morning i had
three big scoops of wild rice i have
smoked
alaskan salmon wild alaskan salmon i
also had um a couple of tomatoes i had a
banana
i had two
four ounce cups of yogurt gluten-free
yogurt
uh let's see here i had the eggs i had
the rice i had the fish and then i had
all my supplements
and
so this is
um something i've been doing for a long
time i'm 82 years old and most people
think i'm in my 50s when they look at me
they can't believe it say well how could
you have done all that stuff well i said
well i'm 82 years old uh
i've been a physician since 1982
okay and so
what can i say
well and there's something that i want
to point out about you know the
the things that you just mentioned dr
wallach
we're looking at whole foods
we're not looking at things that are
pre-packaged from a box
i mean other than the supplements you
know
putting all those nice wonderful raw
ingredients together
but it's not something that's processed
full of fillers
that's
right well and a lot of people say it's
just convenient
well i'll tell you what it doesn't take
long at all to
cook up a piece of
steak
or a piece of fish
yeah you put it in the microwave yeah
put it in the microwave for three
minutes
well no i wouldn't even use a microwave
but still
on low heat some butter and put it in a
put it in a pan
yum yum you bake it in the oven
you know it's not hard folks to eat
right
and to cut out the things that
and so many people think oh it's so hard
to go gluten-free
well
no not if you stick with whole
foods you stick with your whole meat so
you stick with your whole vegetables
you know yeah yeah you don't have to
give up some gluten-free pizza with four
different cheeses and eight different
vegetables
and this is
made with cauliflower yeah it's made
with cauliflower and rice crust
right
you know if that's something that that
you have to have then you know there's
alternatives you know the kids and
grandkids have to have it grandpa we
want pizza okay you're gonna have
gluten-free pizza they don't know that
they just know it tastes good
right
no i i know i still have a nine-year-old
at home that thinks he requires pizza a
couple times a night
well there you go gluten-free pizza
definitely all right so let's go to the
next question that is sent in through
email dr wallach and this is from dj
dj is a truck driver
and
he said a few months ago his doctor told
him he had high cholesterol
he's been on a statin of 10 milligrams
and everything seemed good
um he went to get his dot physical and
his blood pressure is around 125
to 135 over 80 up and down it goes
to a normal
now his dot doctor wants to put him on a
blood pressure medication
um
and he he thinks that once you get on
blood once you get on meds you don't get
off but he wants to do something
naturally to bring his blood pressure
down
okay do we know how much this guy weighs
um
184 pounds
at 56 years old
and
looks like 5 foot 11.
okay
well we love truckers because we can't
get our stuff without truckers bringing
it to us
people can't get stuff without them
bringing our stuff to the people so we
love truckers and so
um cholesterol doctors are confused
about that
he should not be on statin drugs to
lower cholesterol
the cholesterol really should be between
350 and 500 doctors want to get your
cholesterol down below 200 because
they believe falsely it's a false belief
but they believe falsely that
cholesterol is the cause of blocked
arteries no blocked arteries are fried
foods and gluten
okay it has nothing to do with
cholesterol
so the normal cholesterol should be
between 300 350 to 500.
all right
then i wanted to have none of the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils or glutens or wheat berries no
sugar
um no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go he can use our rebound
or sports drink with 100 nutrients in it
has 75 minerals and 25 vitamins
uh and amino acids and we
it was made for theo ratliff our our
great basketball player
and so we have so many professional
athletes olympic athletes and university
athletes and um
people who are just sort of hobby
athletes
people go to the gym all the time use
our are rebound we we sell a lot of
rebound
it comes in cans and individual servings
when i'm on the road i use the
individual servings because the case of
cans is too heavy to take on the
airplane
and
it comes in canisters
so you just take a scoop and throw it in
your drink or something like that
there's all kinds of ways to use the
rebound
and um then um i wanted to have two
healthy brained heart packs per month
two healthy brain and heart patterns per
month full goal setting twice a day i
wanted to have two bottles a month over
msm so you can take three with each meal
and that will support and promote mains
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes the bone itself and
including the walls of the arteries and
then i'm going to have three
of the
ultimate daily classic tablets at
breakfast lunch and dinner that'll be
three bottles a month and they will
support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and if
um
let's say here if um
he's already on medication for blood
pressure do not cold turkey off of it
but as you know he needs to test his
blood pressure all the time and as his
blood pressure slowly comes down he can
slowly reduce the medication level based
on the numbers
and that way there won't be any calamity
okay and so um this is all very simple
stuff for trucker habit pressure
cholesterol issues
and of course just remember 95 of
testosterone is cholesterol not 75 of
your brain weight is cholesterol
do not give up cholesterol just don't
fry it don't you know don't burn it
don't
roast it until it burns
right but but there's nothing wrong with
red meat
i just don't eat it burnt
i love red meat dr welling
uh carnivore i you know what i am so
thankful
that um
yeah i never heard that from you don't
eat red meat
no no you'll never hear that
so and my favorite vegetarians happen to
be beef but anyways well well
i i eat i eat vegetarians every day
that's right we eat vegetarians every
day yeah i eat vegetarians every day i
ate them with tomatoes and
artichokes and stuff like that
oh yeah
all right um it looks like christy might
have another question we are coming to
the top of the hour so christy go ahead
and unmute yourself
let's see if we can get her back
otherwise while we're waiting for her to
unmute herself
um i have another question dr wallach
and that has to do with dry skin
what do you recommend
as a lotion
or a solution for dry skin
well first of all
it's kind of like
putting paint on top of a rusted iron
you don't want to be doing that and so
if you have dry skin you want to get to
the root cause of it and
skin requires a lot of nutrition it has
several different layers uh two-thirds
of skin is connective tissue like
tendons and ligaments
all right
but then it has to grow hair and all
this other stuff and so
um it requires a lot of nutrition
so people with dry skin they got to get
rid of all the bad stuff no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks neither the diet one's
got to go and then one healthy branded
heart pack for 100 pounds of body weight
um three twice a day of the tablets of
the msm which is one bottle a month per
100 pounds of body weight there's a big
bottle you can do that that'll take care
of connective tissue including skin then
three twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight tests two vowels a month of the
hair skin and nails of the hair skin and
nails
now we have all kinds of lotions that
you can put on for temporary relief but
that's not for a permanent
issue okay you can get some temporary
relief because in a couple of weeks the
dry skin thing will be over with if you
treat it properly from the inside
because if you just put
the lotion on and don't heal the inside
you're gonna get some bad problems in
your ligaments and tendons and your legs
and your
arms and neck and all kinds of stuff
um
and so the skin is just kind of like a
red warning light going off uh when
you're when you're having dry skin
issues so there's nothing wrong with
putting some of our lotion we have like
five or six different lotions
um which i don't need to use oh i'm 82
years old i don't need to use them
because my skin is so moist i have all
the hair on my arms and everything and
no problem there
but i take three of those
i just take just for prevention i take
three of the hair skin and nails twice a
day i've been doing that since we came
out with that product i know about 12 15
years ago whatever it is
and um it's just a really blessing and i
had to clip my fingernails
once a week because they grow so long
with their skin and nails
and also the msm i'm sure contributes to
it
but um
that's the way i'd go with the dry skin
issue
all right and so
i have a few favorites dr wallach of
course i do it just because of habit
um but i love our and i love the fact
that youngevity has done this
when they find a company that has an
amazing product
we work out a way to incorporate them
into our family of products
and we have the beyond organics
with
um
skin care
products we also have the nature pearl
that has skin care
i love our muscadine
lotion
and also the um toothpaste so if you're
looking for a non-toxic toothpaste we've
got that as well
um and you're so right when it comes to
nails and how fast they grow and for
ladies who get their nails done
um i could get my nails filled every
single week
they grow so fast
and so i think it's absolutely fabulous
when you give your body what it needs
the amazing things that it can do
um on its own
now that muscadine
grape seed is one of our
favorite products is people love it
oh it's it's amazing so not only do we
have it in the the lotion and the skin
care but it also comes in the extract it
also comes in
capsules
and and dr upwallick if you wanted to
share any of the benefits of the
muscadine grape
please feel free
okay well basically what it does is it
facilitates
the
um
the process of making hair and skin and
nails and so forth
and
the grape
of course is a wonderful wonderful
product makes wine
everybody loves that part but also the
seeds produce these
these nutrients
that very few other plants produce in
the quantity
that grape seeds do so the muscadine
grapes which are the big grapes um
produce this
substance which we use as a product
and so um
it is actually an organic product that's
made by the grapes
but it's anti-inflammatory but it does
stimulate the growth
of hair
and nails and healthy skin
yeah and and it's absolutely wonderful
absolutely all right looks like we lost
the
um audio for christy
um
and we are
four minutes to the top of the hour do
you want to take one more question or do
you have anything else that you want to
use as a closing dr wallach
well again i want to remind everybody to
go to you or to go to me
www.drjwallet.com
browse through there i think we got 15
books
and each one of those books is going to
become a chapter
in this newest book called the third
testament
and i'm going to be like 12 inches thick
12 inches oh no no it'd have to be four
feet thick
well i'm looking i'm looking at you know
my desk here with the books that i have
and i mean they themselves are over 12
inches so you're adding
you're probably like four
feet yeah
but but you know why rewrite those
chapters when the book's already written
and so it has all the references and
people will be able to follow up and
look up what they want to look up and so
forth and so i'm very very excited about
this and just remember we deal with over
600 different diseases
we deal with over 600 different diseases
um with these products we've been doing
it for 50 years i've been doing it for
50 years
and we're all over the world we're in 60
countries
and we're growing i should really ask
because we might be in 65 countries
right now as we speak i just can't keep
up
we have bought two big brand new
manufacturing plants
in
on the east coast i think they're all in
both of them are in
florida
and these two manufacturing plants
uh the people who were building them
went out of business so we were able to
buy them and the reason why we bought
them we're going to make some of the
products that get back ordered on
occasion
because not because of us but because
the manufacturers have a difficult time
in getting the amount of the raw
materials they need to make those
products so we're going to eliminate a
lot of back orders by manufacturing
these things ourselves we're going to
take over that responsibility so
coming next year
the back order stuff will not be a
problem anymore because we have these
two big manufacturing plants i mean
they're big they're huge
and
we're not talking about grandma's back
room we're
talking about you know um
5 000 square feet 10 000 square feet
kind of things and so i'm very excited
about this
it's our next generation
of making sure that all the people
excuse me have access to everything they
want when they want it
and um
as you say we're already negotiating
with several other companies that are
going under financially because they
didn't have the army that we built we
built an army over the last 50 years of
people like yourself
um and your team
we have armies all over the world
that are bringing this information to
their families and to their neighbors
and their church mates and their temple
mates and and so forth and their
classmates and their workmates and their
um and um i knew we had to have an army
in the beginning
um because
even god
has 12
apostles okay
even god has all these apostles
because
you know
he can only talk to one person at a time
i mean he can make a thunderstorm he can
make an earthquake and send a message
but for somebody to hold somebody's hand
and talk to him you need an army and so
that's what we need to do and we we've
been very successful in doing this
um not only do we help people add 25 to
50 healthy years of their life
but also
we can help them financially with tax
breaks because an employee does not get
tax breaks when you own your own home
business you get the same tax breaks
that billionaires get
and um this includes your supplements or
the cost your supplements are tax
deductible because in your little
business plan we have a book called um
let's see what is it um
wall street for kids
wall street for kids there you go wall
street for kids wall street for kids
and um
it'll teach you how to build a business
plan that you can have all these tax
breaks
and uh you'll be able to get what you
need for your supplements for yourself
and your family
and
um
this is not difficult
but
it's one of those things that people if
your family is a working family and they
just always have been employees all
their life they don't know about these
things because it's something that only
people who own businesses can
utilize well and i i love being able to
have purpose
dr wallach
i mean we're
we're
in a world that's hurting
for
information well the world needs rebecca
and her world needs rebecca and her team
well i love my team
and
i we are fine just fantastic there's
great dynamic in it dr wellick and
i have to thank you again because if it
wasn't for you i would not have met
these wonderful people
jaunty and nasima and ruth allen and
so many more that are online with us dr
wallach just part of your
crusade
and again you know waking up with
purpose i mean i've made a career out of
this
where i mean i
i've done a lot of things in my life i
was a statistician
and you're making you're making a
reasonable you're making a reasonable
amount of income for your efforts right
um absolutely if it wasn't for my
longevity business we would have lost
the farm seriously
so i am very thankful for my youngevity
business
well there you go very thankful
um okay yeah and i encourage everybody
if you have an interest in
just doing things on more natural scale
and helping the people around you
find a
healthier option
to doing life
we encourage you to get back with the
person that shared this program with you
or go to our website askdoclive.com
use the contact us
and we can get you information also on
how you can start your very own business
with us
on this amazing crusade
on behalf of this crew here with ask doc
live and dr wallach thank you again
for another two two hours of great
information
um
we thank you everybody for taking this
time and
you know just
we hope this is added value
in your
search for information
we'll be back next friday
same place same time
bye for now
thank you so much rebecca i'm off to
australia right now
all right
bye-bye
bye everybody
bye bye we're selling bye-bye to sema by
my auntie